[Music]
let me talk about something with you B
let me talk about I know what you're
thinking this this is a misdirect and
you're going to be so excited and I
misdirect oh you think this is a brand
in shop segment it's not
it's a big gay lion segment pgl
okay let's do it baby how many calories
does Mark hardly eat in a day I don't
care but how much calorie hey do me a
favor Frozen look at how much calorie
[ __ ] has
thank you and times that times
[Laughter]
where where are you first you completely
left you hanging by yourself you're
drowning damn it [ __ ] virtually like
oh Frozen's here I don't gotta work oh
um dude I'm here I'm sorry my [ __ ]
life is [ __ ] up I've been muted for
so long
Marky
I have zero self-consciousness it's
disgusting maybe I should you ever seen
Marky
zero self-consciousness it's disgusting
maybe I should I mean I don't think
you're aware of it it's literally like
the Cookie Monster but with like lasagna
no look people it's a Garfield Garfield
Garfield Garfield if it's lasagna
Garfield you stupid [ __ ] oh my God it's
a basic joker I'm sorry they don't teach
that they don't teach that at the San
Francisco comedy College
well he didn't go he didn't attend Mark
might correct him
he might be like well actually uh Park
my [ __ ] you
uh give it a chance when I used to do my
a b improv exercises uh yes and yes
from earlier 5 to 25 calories okay you
know who actually does eat like that too
hold on I'm updating my Fitbit okay
you're an [ __ ] sorry guys such an ass
look at that no does it say [ __ ] uh
Alex Rosen eats like that he eats like a
madman like a Tasmanian devil that makes
sense
almost everyone whoever sees me eat
because it's a few different things I
mean sloppiness would be one vector but
also the speed at which I eat seems to
frighten people they're like how many
calories do you take a day
the upper limit is very high I usually
don't you know so it's like I only when
we're on the road and we go somewhere
it's like yeah you know but my ten
thousand calories in a day but normally
like three thousand yeah talk about time
by asked him a question am I interrupt
and B I I asked him a question I'm gonna
interrupt them though while he answers
it yeah I don't care but the but but
when you eat no one cares but when you
eat uh slow down uh when you
this is a new thing who's he stealing
from now he he adds things he adds new
things to his repertoire to his to his
Voltron of shittiness to eat do you it's
like you eat like you're in the military
like we're rushing you yeah to go off
the floor yeah people will be like
prisoners
like the Chow like the Chow yard like
they don't have a lot of time yeah like
you're an Navy SEAL and it's like you
have like 20 like you know they have
like something there's no rush whatever
did you grow up with Brothers I did and
I remember having this
family blew up like
not poor but like I just I there was it
wasn't my limit it wasn't yeah like I'd
go over to other people so I was like oh
you guys have a pantry like that's crazy
like you just have unlimited food yeah
where did you live the zoo yeah I mean I
was poor but we had a pantry with food
in it um didn't have a pantry it might
have been poor food but it was still
sure the cereal was in bags and not in
boxes but at a pantry because like
that's the gallon of milk and I'm
getting to it before you do so I don't
know but like no that's that's I don't
feel any self-conscious about it I
probably should because it immediately
reveals it's like oh this person didn't
grow up with money or whatever but
there's nothing wrong with that no I
don't know
okay I'm sorry
as somebody we do shows together in
person and remote how do you not figure
out how not to talk over each other by
now I don't get it it's not that hard
it's it's Amateur hour [ __ ] it's mostly
Brendan yeah
sure good point
I have a big family and food is not
abundant yeah you you get you're not
getting seconds unless you hurry up yeah
so the face is so big because it's Coke
blow Papa you've not seen so neat like
I would say maybe I don't know speed
especially because people will be like
maybe people could eat more in a contest
or something like that but as far as
pure speed I've never seen anything like
that yeah never in my life they clipped
this this was a segment that they
thought wait this is their clip
fighter in the kitchen I thought I
thought somebody clipped this just to
make fun of a big gay lion
I pulled this because I was like oh my
God they clipped this what there's
nothing to this story other than how
many calories he eats like didn't the
kogi truck burrito like it's a Korean
burritos you ate it before we even got
six of those in five minutes without a
drink like or I should say my the BET
was he brags like a child
amen who brags about how much food they
eat when they're like 40. like who does
that that could eat six so you're not
like I got the sixth one in my mouth I
feel like you're not there's just no
substance to this man yeah he's very
he's nothing behind muscles gay mate
lion's mane and calories
food that's sort of that's what bothers
me right you're not tasting I do because
my taste buds function but people always
say that too like you know you're not
tasting the food I am and that's what
makes me want more of it
I know I could it's a for example when I
go to a nice restaurant like a French
restaurant or something I do I'll be
like oh man every bite is really good
and I do know what that feels like to do
that
he knows what it feels like this clip's
almost over what's the point of this
clip I'm hoping hear me out on this okay
I'm hoping it ends with a massive like
gas explosion yeah that makes sense
because then you go well now I know how
they clipped it everybody wants to I
would have titled it differently I
wouldn't entitled to it okay hear me out
remember the great white concert yes
like something like that so maybe like a
fire breaks out but they're also locked
in and terrified and banging on the
walls this would be great good ending by
the way when I say great white concert I
didn't mean Kenny Chesney I meant like
the app and great white
um but sometimes I feel like you like
putting away the food I'll be like oh
[ __ ] I need to pretend like I eat slow
right that's gonna say when you go on a
date is your girl like hey man yes it's
almost like farting in front of a girl
it's like oh now you know that I like do
these gross things I have enough
self-consciousness to be like if I'm
trying to impress somebody I won't eat
like a maniac but yeah
that's it
that was the clip it's the clip okay
maybe he's a little better on he wants
somebody else's show looks like [ __ ]
Adonis Paul but I guess not
um bulking for football season like I
can't do this you know my football coach
called me out because we would do this
like five mile hill run every week on
like Fridays and he saw me on the way to
it and I was like oh yeah coach like I'm
actually I'm trying to gain weight right
now he's like oh so you can't run for 45
minutes
okay what about equipoise or or Deca or
anything like that it's always like so
like how much Trend should I take I'm
like this is your first cycle like and
you barely lift weights or whatever you
know I'm sure you get this a lot too
where it's just like well we already
know because listen merch if you ever
want to get into the dark arts of
steroids yeah they're called the dark
arts well that's because I associate it
with Trenton we are you an end person
so I'm more of an ass person
I'm the S person
you're the potato end person
um
so the person I'm gonna listen to is the
guy who said don't go to the doctor get
your blood work done just School in dark
web you'll figure it out you'll figure
out the right mixture for you
please guys if you're hearing this do
not if you're ever I don't I do not
frown on people that take steroid cycles
but do research and do it right okay
you've your mind has been hacked into
thinking this is the first step that you
this guy goes to the [ __ ] opens the
tour browser goes to real steroids.biz
and he just [ __ ] defies that I guess
Jesus is actual debit card because he's
an idiot yeah getting jacked and it's
just not [ __ ] his email the real
markharley gmail.com through it all um
now I was gonna it's been romanticized
yeah just like sport sports cards
everybody wants a Ferrari yeah but
there's hundreds of sports cars I don't
want a Ferrari
Ferrari right you know and it's the same
I don't want to this guy's really over
valuing how much people want Ferraris if
I was if I was rich right now
I would just get a much nicer version of
the car I have now like something like
the same like like an SUV that's just
loaded with nice stuff and it costs like
60 Grand like you know what I mean yeah
there's there is a cap
to how much enjoyment you're gonna get
out of an item when it goes from like 60
80 grand to like 250 Grand it's like it
just gets a 60 Grand car you're gonna
get in it you're gonna be comfy you know
what I mean winter time you can have a
heated steering wheel what else do you
really [ __ ] need the only thing that
really wants a Ferrari is like my high
school Trapper Keeper
high school
it's so cool then you're like what's the
gas mileage
the first time my question isn't how
fast it is like
instead of Android auto and
um
but steroids there's there's multiple
steroids you can take because with a
Ferrari too the minute a shopping cart
touches it lightly you're gonna wipes
over that's it but ask about like or
comment on you doing the uh fasting
mimicking diet and losing a lot of
muscle then putting it right back on but
before that I was going to say
um the Roid Rage thing because we kind
of trend is almost like synonymous when
you think of like people who are
actually rotate yes Trend will make you
angry here's the thing with that's like
the notorious one just like a Deca let's
do that right it's equivalent to like
tequila makes you [ __ ] work makes you
kind of worse than other boots for some
people trends like that the thing is
with roadways it is over it is overblown
because Roid Rage doesn't make somebody
who's calm crazy it makes somebody who's
a crazy crazier does that make sense if
if you're somebody who's already a
[ __ ] hot head make somebody who's
calm Moody yeah Moody sure but yeah you
if you're blowing up on transits because
you're a guy that was either blowing up
all the time or blowing up often enough
that you you're a guy who blows up or a
new Kevin Sullivan and had a Bowflex
I have nothing to do with that all right
I was far away I can trend
the most I've taken as 100 milligrams
per day per 10 days the real thing I
noticed was
they're taking a hundred milligrams of
trend a day for five days ten days he
said 10 I'm sorry ten they're 10 that's
why I made the face I was like that's a
lot
that's a lot of trend if they're
stacking it with something super horny
and also my workout suffered like your
cardiovascular capacity that's the first
time I'm like oh I'm getting it yeah
yeah yeah I'm doing six sets of biceps
you were doing
a hundred milligrams
because I thought he was talking about
someone else a nice confirmed
of trend not a weekly shot because I
know some people that you know only
three 300 milligrams a week right of
trend and probably stacking it with a
bunch of other stuff but you're taking
that much what is wrong with you
do you understand that you can get the
same result but that's the issues like
even steroids there's diminishing
returns at a certain point right it
doesn't matter how much you take your
body is going to be that's it your
body's like this is it so that's a
ridiculous amount of trend and by the
way Trenton could back me up on this I'm
sure
and I just want to quit you know
um it's not comfortable you know but I
just had like a bunch of stuff on hand
and I'm like oh I'm gonna shoot a music
video in a couple weeks like if I just
take 100 milligrams of wind straw or
sorry 200 milligrams one straw a day 100
milligrams Trend a day 100 milligrams
yeah
thank you Trenton Wade he's probably
doing Trend a which is a which is daily
to every which is daily to every other
day man having Trenton here is so great
yeah so the funny thing is like trim
below and it it's a progesterone
compound so it can activate the
progesterone receptor a little bit
that's why some guys get thicker skin on
trembolone yeah it's mostly absolutely
dandelion but with germ blowing it
happens also and then there's some
there's a little bit of evidence that
wind stroke can inhibit I remember
reading that back in the day okay but
here's the thing you have to remember a
big a line bigger lines that even
competing
so he's taking
if Mr Olympia was doing this I'd be like
you got to do what it takes bro you're
top tier yeah because you've everyone
that that's like the Pinnacle of
perfection I think it looks gross but
you know what my mother looks gross but
yeah but but but I get it but you're
doing this to be a podcast producer
he's doing this because he can't get
laid or have anything going in his life
unless he looks like a big gay lion
and then you're always going to get
Typecast as a big muscular [ __ ] you
big muscular [ __ ]
any